This next clip is sort of funny, but it's
also it's also kind of sad.
I don't know why I kind of got bummed out
watching it.
Dr. Anthony Fauci was on CNN yesterday with
Wolf Blitzer and Wolf Blitzer tried to make
a baseball analogy to the pandemic.
And the analogy was, Dr. Fauci, you like baseball?
I like baseball.
If this pandemic were a baseball game, what
inning would we be in?
And Dr. Fauci just seeming exhausted, saying,
you know, Wolf, this isn't like baseball,
but I actually think there is a baseball analogy
that could be made that Dr. Fauci could use
in the future.
I'll tell you in a second.
But let's take a look at the clip.
Are we Dr. Fauci is a country right now in
our fight against this virus?
We're both baseball fans, for example.
What inning are we in?
You know you know, it's not like baseball,
Wolf, because the inning that we're in is
going to depend on how we respond.
And that's the issue because I mean, if I
say we're in the seventh inning, it's almost
over and we have surges like we're seeing
throughout Europe and the rest of the world.
And the threat of a surge that we're seeing
now, you know, it's not measured in innings
anymore.
It's measured on what we do to contain this.
OK, so Dr. Fauci is correct in the sense that
we're only in the seventh inning.
If people behave one way and otherwise, it
might really only be like the fourth inning
or the fifth inning and we have a long way
to go.
Here is me workshopping a better baseball
analogy.
Tell me what you think about this.
You know, Wolf, the pandemic isn't a game.
It's really like a World Series where you
have to win four games to actually win.
So the question is, are we going to sweep
this in four or is it going to go seven because
we don't finish off the virus as quickly as
we could.
Right.
That's the baseball analogy.
What I can tell you, Wolf, is we have one
more game to win, but will it be a sweep or
will this go seven games?
Right.
You could maybe you could even go further.
Game one, testing and controlling the spread
game to scaling up testing and researching
vaccines.
Game three, developing and testing the vaccines
game for finishing vaccination to end the
pandemic.
And then next year, you might have another
World Series, right.
Variants, potentially new vaccines.
The other baseball analogy I was thinking
of that might work would be listen, Wolf.
We're in the seventh inning, but the virus
is trying to catch up, and if they do and
and we have a tie, then we go extra innings.
And as you know, Wolf, extra innings can go
on indefinitely until someone wins.
And we don't want that every time a red state
doesn't have enough people wanting the vaccine.
The virus has just knocked in a single.
If the virus gets enough of these singles,
it's going to start putting runs up on the
board.
My going too far with this.
Regardless, we all share Dr. Falsies exhaustion
with this.
If it's game four and you can finish it off
or have to play another game, you power through
the exhaustion.
And that's what we're hopefully doing with
three and a half million vaccinations a day.
We're going to have to deal with the pause
on the Johnson and Johnson vaccine over the
blood clot fears, as I told you earlier.
But big picture.
I mean, do you think it's a problem that Wolf
Blitzer and others use these whether it's
sports analogies or whatever the case may
be like?
On one hand, there really is no analogy to
something with a defined duration because
the duration is is whatever we make it.
New Zealand, just stop this.
You could say they walked off the field after
the first inning and said we don't have to
play the rest of the game because there's
almost nothing left to do.
They controlled it so.
Well, I don't know.
I don't know if maybe the sports analogies
or the fight analogies that are sometimes
used, maybe it makes it more relatable.
Maybe it just makes it more confusing to people.
Let me know what you think.